cyprus cannot tackle this massive and
fast spreading fire alone
and has now appealed for international
help to prevent more loss of life
and destruction of property
strong winds after a week-long heat wave
have created a toxic
mix for firefighters working in the
southern coastal region
[Music]
helicopters dozens of fire engines and
water tankers have been mobilized
with greece italy and israel offering
help
british troops stationed in cyprus are
already involved in the effort
the blaze which began on saturday has
forced the evacuation of many homes
and search crews found the bodies of
four people outside
one fire swept mountain village
the dead are believed to be egyptian
laborers and plans are being made to
repatriate their remains
[Music]
residents who lost their homes have
vented their fury at the government
claiming the authorities were slow to
respond to what officials have described
as the worst forest fire in the history
of cyprus
a catastrophic blaze still burning and
one which police say could have been
started
deliberately they've arrested a 67 year
old man
on suspicion of arson michelle clifford
sky news